[Music]  i watch the oscars because  [Music]  you're going to make me cry i watch the  oscars because i love  cinema to me it's like a sports game who  is going to be the winner this year i  love celebrating cinema with my peers  the oscars has represented  a sort of nirvana of filmmaking  i know that i will see somebody like  me being recognized for all the hard  work that they've achieved  and i want to be up there one day i  watch the oscars because i love movies  and i love clothes i love crying  at everybody's emotional speeches  culture is important that's it  i've wrote a quote on my school desk and  on all of my notebooks  it's a quote from marilyn monroe i'm  going to be a great movie star  someday  [Music]